metal gear is a series known for its
Easter eggs so many in fact that there's
already a gist episode highlighting very
best secrets from the history of the
franchise
let's since so many of you are cracking
into the newest Metal Gear installment I
thought I'd cover off on five awesome
Easter eggs from the phantom pain that
some of you clever people have gone and
found - spoilers do lie ahead
silent Hills may not be happening but
it's playable teaser PT does make an
appearance in the phantom pain and not
just in the easter-egg we already knew
about last week on in two minutes
Lucy reminded you that you can find
Petey's Lisa ghost in the phantom pain
as an active decoy balloon we now know
that it becomes available once you've
expanded your mother base with an R&D
team that is advanced enough to upgrade
to this seriously freaky decoy
that's not although during the locate
and rescue Shabani mission you can
stumble across a campsite with a radio
that's playing a crime news report this
report is the same chilling murder story
that played in PT in the prologue of the
game there's a fairly interesting play
you can spot in a hospital hallway at
one point snake will pull himself onto a
nearby railing next to a bulletin board
where you can get a close-up view of
what is probably the Phantom Pain's
first Easter Egg the board showcases a
Kojima Productions flyer featuring snake
from ground zeroes and the message
joined the Fox team also shown is the
booth number CP 2308 which was the
number assigned to Kojima Productions at
2013 s Game Developers Conference a lot
of dev recruitment happens at GDC so
there you go poster makes sense next up
you can grab yourself a sweet old-school
solid snake skin this one already
featured in ground zeroes but if you
want to play through Metal Gear Solid 5
as a polygonal Metal Gear Solid 1 era
Solid Snake this is the secret for you
all you need to do is complete the deja
vu mission in ground zeroes and transfer
your save to get the ability to research
this old-school skin among other rewards
snake is an incredibly cool dude
sometimes though it's hilarious to see
an incredibly cool dude get knocked on
his ass this easter egg really nails it
in that department early on in the game
mother base is peppered with safety
posters warning you about the under
construction work site third posters
depict a stick figure getting smacked
with falling boxes if you sidle up next
to one of these posters and
it for a little while you'll hear a
Looney Tunes esque whistle before
watching snake get knocked to the ground
by a big box it's pretty damn funny
let's watch it again
don't worry snake live inland and
finally there's my absolute favorite
Easter Egg that fans have found so far
snakes birthday at the start of Metal
Gear Solid 5 the phantom pain you're
asked to enter your birthday if you
happen to play the game on this day
snake will be called back to base for a
supposed emergency what you'll find
though is a surprise party complete with
cake and birthday tunes and a gift cigar
it's downright adorable and when you
wander around the base afterward some of
your men will wish you happy birthday
steak house the best friends let me know
down in the comments if you found any
particularly cool Easter eggs from the
phantom pain and which has been your
favorite so far i'll catch again next
week
you